ويبدو ان هناك الكثير من سبل الحمايه في
مثل هذه الاوقات منها ما هو قبل الهزه
كتحديد اماكن امنه في الخارج بعيدا عن
الابنيه والاشجار وعدم التوجه الى المناطق
الساحليه خوفا من حدوث موجات مد عاتيه اما
اثناء الهزه فلا تبادر الى الخروج او
النزول الى الملجا فالبقاء في الداخل اسلم
ابتعد عن النوافذ واحمي الراس والوجه بما
امكن وفي حال كان الشخص خارج المنزل وفي
السياره يجب ركن السياره بعيدا عن المباني
والامدادات الكهربائيه العامه وعدم عبور
الجسور ودخول الانفاق اما بعد حصول الهزه
فاذا كنت مصابا حافظ على هدوئك وتجنب
صدمات الخوف والهلع واذا لم تتعرض لاي
اصابه اخمد الحرائق الصغيره واقطع جميع
مصادر الطاقه واستعد لحدوث هزات ارتداديه
قبل حدوثها